como nunca antes
así se propaga el virus que genera el
kobe 19 en el continente americano esta
es la más reciente conclusión de la
organización panamericana de la salud un
repunte impulsado por el avance de la
variante omicron ante la cual la ope se
pide no bajar la guardia
aunque las infecciones por un micro
parecen ser más leves seguimos pidiendo
precaución porque el virus se está
propagando más activamente que nunca
las vacunas nos protegen de los peores
síntomas el kobe 19 y reducen nuestras
posibilidades de requerir atención
hospitalaria es que con 72 millones de
nuevos casos registrados en la última
semana la ope se destaca el aumento en
las hospitalizaciones en eeuu y canadá
incrementos también constatados en
paraguay uruguay y argentina los picos
de infecciones afectan a colombia perú
bolivia pero sobre todo a brasil el
gigante sudamericano registró un nuevo
récord superando por primera vez los
200.000 casos diarios mientras el país
avanza con la vacunación para niños
entre los 5 y los 11 años podríamos
y
podríamos haber iniciado antes de esta
vacunación pero el ministerio de salud
se quedó discutiendo promoviendo
audiencias y otras sin utilidades y
otros sin utilidades en ecuador' un
aumento de 185 por ciento de los casos
registrados en la última semana llevaron
a quitó entrar en alerta roja ante el
preocupante panorama regional la ope se
hace un llamado a priorizar las pruebas
rápidas de antígenos para personas
sintomáticas aunque el 60% de los
habitantes de américa latina y el caribe
cuentan con un esquema completo de
vacunación el organismo urge a frenar la
propagación usando además de las vacunas
otras herramientas como el
distanciamiento las mascarillas y la
cancelación de eventos masivos